you
[Music]
I'll be talking about pressed which is
fast sequel engine that can run on
basically any data I'm curious who
already is using presto or heard about
quest and the audience okay I see some
hands get good alright okay cool so the
short history of Presta is about six
years six years old open source project
first developed by Facebook for their
internal usage to basically make queries
fast again right because after moving to
two big HDFS and dealing with petabytes
of data all the skuas became really slow
and hive wasn't able to run
interactively at that time so the builds
a new engine from scratch completely so
my team is actually part of the Preston
community for over three years by now
and we converted a bunch of features I
will talk about them later but in a
natural press that is essentially a
great sequel engine it's not a data
warehouse it doesn't own your data you
keep your data in your own favorite
format whether that's cloud storage or
HDFS or any kind of storage and you can
actually see a long list of connectors
oppress two ships wave today that you
can connect to from presto right so you
can issue sequel statements and refer to
your data your tables define either the
HDFS or as free or blob storage or my
sequel or Cassandra and a bunch of
others right and this list of connectors
two different data sources for pressure
grows basically every month because you
know lots of companies using this
software and there are contributing
connectors to the platform stats they
want to query so you know not only you
can query individual platforms itself
you can actually drive queries that are
joining tables from multiple data
sources at once right which makes it
pretty pretty amazing tool for so
virtualizing data access right and then
because it's a sequel engine
the team is actually aiming to provide
for sequel unsecure compatibility you
can actually use a bunch of VI tools and
sequel development tools notebooks and
all sorts of different tools to access
presto itself you can still obviously
write your queries by hand if you prefer
and put them on come online right but
most of your users will be more
comfortable with those VI tools um ok so
you might be curious like who are purse
to users there's actually a lot of them
already
and and the giant is user is obviously
Facebook because they develop this in
the first place and and they invest a
lot in the project still and so from
thousands of nodes but there's long list
of other companies so from from
financial to media telco all over the
place
they can small companies and if you are
already using Presta but you are not on
this list lets me know let me know and I
will fix it if you are not on this list
and you are not yet using using press to
let me know we can fix it too right
ok so some of the biggest users and have
press to in production are yes Facebook
battles over Twitter lived near length
in Netflix so all the big guys are using
this technology already at massive scale
right so so we can run classes hundreds
note speech crystal scales and reliable
and highly concurrence equal access and
and purse that's pretty unique because
can run like both cloud on premises can
in a virtualized environment so it's
very very flexible how we want to apply
it that's why it's popular among all
those different applications right it
doesn't try to shovel you into like one
way to do things right so we can roll
your own infrastructure if you want so
for example Netflix was originally using
this in the cloud using standard ec2
instances
last year they started magnet in this to
a container based environment and they
have they're not running using
kubernetes
something they developed in-house what
is basically sort of flexible container
infrastructure so you can scale number
of containers whenever your workload
increases for a particular application
so a quick overview of presto
architecture to enable this parallelism
and scale obviously it's running on
multiple nodes and as I mentioned it's
very flexible how you want to deploy it
but essentially ins of logical
architecture you have one coordinator
which is really a brain of the system
and multiple workers that actual query
processing so the coordinator will
accept a psycho statement from the
client and then you know those of
sundered parsing analyzing and planning
the query execution and then scheduler
will take her of sort of orchestrating
that actual parallel execution of that
query across the workers the workers
themselves basically they kind of read
the data from the storage and then
basically apply all the processing like
protections selections aggregation
drawings and they kind of all
collaborate to compute the query and
curry obviously in this example doesn't
show that that the query may be obvious
in multiple stages lots of different
operations but at the end there is a
final result that was returned to the
client it's pretty unique in presto
versus other sequel engines is that it's
actually pretty pluggable that whole
storage layer that I was showing at the
bottom that on the first slide is
essentially a pluggable thing which
means you are not tied to any specific
data source there's actually API to
develop connectors to all your storage
engines so in this picture I'm showing
foot different pieces of that API so
there's metadata API which allows Presta
to understand you know what are the
tables and schema and columns and data
types that are exposed by your data
source and to presto
so presto
understand the sort of the relational
mapping from your actual data source to
to serve sequel standard objects and
then there is data location API that
essentially allows for us to understand
how to paralyze the execution of the
query right if your data source is just
single node my sequel database it will
be essentially like a single threaded
access right but if you're if you can
say mark shard with my sequel then that
data location API you can implement that
the way that exposes that parison to
presto so that multiple personal workers
can read data in parallel from your
storage and achieve great speed up and
then actual workers have data stream API
which is essentially okay I go to this
data parallel union what do I do with it
I got this split right so I just need to
understand how I transform the stream of
bytes that's coming from the data source
and how do I translate this into rows
and columns that can actually go into
process right and then the rest of the
execution right engine is completely
agnostic towards your data source right
now there are no specific optimizations
for for this or that
format everything is sort of contained
in that connector API right so so that's
that's basically pretty powerful engine
because pretty powerful architecture
because now you can completely replace
your search engine and move from one to
the other and for example say you have
HDFS on-premises you decide to move to
the cloud right your users are
completely unaffected right like the
sequel users they see the same set of
tables similar says the same set of
schemas right and and the quiz will not
change you just sort of move the data
and mapped and prop the mother not that
data properly on two tables so I think
that's that when the architecture is
obviously lots of details that I can
dive into during the office hours but
like I was I'm trying to motivate why
people would use presto and if it's not
obvious already
well Preston has disadvantage because
this is actually community driven
open-source project on unlike many of
these sequel engines especially from the
Hadoop ecosystem if you're coming from
that environment like each open source
project was essentially driven by one of
the vendors right so if you happen to
use a distribution a of Hadoop then
you'll be stuck with hive if you're
using B maybe you have Impala right and
maybe sometimes you get spark sequel but
maybe it's an older version of Spock
sequel that ships with that distribution
so it's pretty much your under you have
your under their influence and control
which you can use on your platform with
presto is pretty amazing because because
of those giant users of presto
there are Driving's of the development
end and the project and and the
community moves essentially based on the
needs of those big users and then if you
need help and if you know you can go to
mailing list control this yourself
right you can you can also ask presto
experts for help so that's that's that
it's pretty amazing
open source project lots of different
initiatives we've built on top of presto
so you might be familiar with Amazon
Athena it was basically they took Presta
and they built a service on top of that
right so it's basically I think another
validation of press to being amazing
sequel enter for for the cloud and those
flexible deployments another big thing
about press stories is high performance
sequel engine you know thanks to some
recent announcements of cost-based
optimizer proven scalability of up to a
thousand nodes and high concurrency use
cases that are around by all those big
companies is basically when you enter a
presto ecosystem you can have this
confidence right that I'm not going to
hit like so some bags that are were not
yet exposed in terms of scale to form as
concurrency right because all those big
big guys already found those bugs and
fixed them
alright so that I think that helps a lot
in adoption
and speaks to the maturity of the
project as well and then a major sort of
fundamental thing which I touched upon
it already is the separation of computed
storage right if you were entering
Hadoop ecosystem say 810 years ago when
I was basically when I started right
looking into Hadoop and Big Data like
there was this mantra
yeah bringing compute to your storage
right like tied them together right
because shipping data is so expensive
right and it's very costly right you
need to bring everything into your
Hadoop cluster everything needs to run
inside right that's no longer true right
all the modern architectures right now
separate storage from compute allow
those two layers in to scale
independently how are we going to grow
your data without limit and also scale
up and down your compute whenever you're
really ready to to pay for additional
compute right and allow you to save
costs of compute when you're not using
your cluster right you're running fewer
queries because of the holiday season
for example right and the fact that
person can access all the different data
sources is also moderate modernizing
your architectures in a sense that you
are not necessarily required to bring
all the data into one place into this
one central data warehouse and that
means to go for all the ETL process and
basically before you can hit the
insights you have to wait a long time
right so you can because of bring some
insights earlier when the data is fresh
in your data source work it was first
arrived arriving right so for example
you can talk to your Cassandra and get
some latest updates from there you can
go to Kafka and fetch latest events from
the Kafka right and combine that with
the historical data so so before sort of
the data is properly transformed into
the optimal long-term storage format so
that's basically it and then I mentioned
this it's community driven
there's no vendor lock-in and what I
mean by this is you're not tied to any
how to prevent
anymore you're not tied to any cloud
vendor right because you can actually
deploy presto in any of the public
clouds you can rent in your private
cloud if you does the strategy your
company pursuing you can you can
basically do it anywhere you want and
then you are tied to a specific storage
engine right so if for example SV
becomes obsolete in ten years right
which seems crazy right now but let's
say it happens right you know there will
be essentially some development
impressed to develop a new connector for
the new data platform and you'll be
still using presto on top of that which
is which is pretty pretty amazing to
sort of separate that responsibilities
so I talked about how Presto's great
answer sequel engine which essentially
means it can basically run most of the
sequel statements you can imagine right
you can take complex workloads from save
redshift or whatever the your favorite
MPP sequel engine today and random on
presto pretty much without much changes
but pressure also spans beyond an SI
sequel by offering a huge long list of
various functions extensions and so some
of the common use cases that we see are
people using this form instead of
parsing your your textual data log data
using Gribble expression functions that
are as huge list of those available in
pressed already there are lambda
functions and expressions they built in
into sequel so that's basically against
extension to presto itself and to unsee
sequel standard what allows you to have
more expressive and more concise
expression of your sequel
transformations and and also geospatial
functions
big new feature not too many people know
about this yet but over a year ago
actually guys from uber developed pretty
neat extensions to presto to allow geo
spatial analytics through sequel and now
the publishers that contributed back to
the community and our facebook also
picked this up and they are putting lots
of effort to optimize execution of those
queries especially if you're doing sort
of with very large data and you're
joining on geospatial conditions other
than standard equi-join conditions and
listening some examples here on the
right so so you can take a quick look
how you might structure those kinds of
computations impressed oh right on
it's pretty pretty amazing that you can
do complex analytics like that in your
Seco using some extensions to it and
then to complement your standard
artistical
datatypes you can also use JSON arrays
Maps
and complex tracts process more of sort
of semi structured data inside presto as
well Oh
so I mentioned up front that there's a
bunch of tools that can work with presto
because breast is open source naturally
some users expect values open source
tools to work for the clients right so
some of the popular tools we see is
Swedish superset was actually coming
from Airbnb and Jupiter notebook as well
so those are so gaining popularity now
but because press ships with JDBC and
ODBC drivers you can connect virtually
any tool that will be working with your
standard on VI and sequel environments
so if you have tableau or things like
this they would need to work sequel
developer even right so whatever works
for you and then people are embedding
presto and Center inside their
applications right so there are lots of
bindings like C go Java on oh right on
and so on so you can actually call out -
presto from all those different
languages using the standard methods
available to in those languages and then
in terms of extend extending presto
right you may have a favorite UDF
function or UG
af right it's like okay I want to make
sure that this runs inside presto right
so Prester has those API so you can
develop those functions follow examples
from our documentation and essentially
deploy a jar with those functions into
presto and you can use that sequel
you'll find new sequel function you
develop inside your sequel statements
easily and then there's the whole
connector SPI which allows you to
develop connectors for data sources that
are not yet supported out of the box and
or you might be touching your internal
systems that are not sort of you know
public interfaces and nobody is able to
develop those connectors so we see
people developing
connectors to their internal platforms
that exposed REST API right and because
this those passwords may serve data and
this data is not available for other
means they may develop a simple
connector to to basically reach out to
those platforms and sort of represent
this data from the rest cause as tables
and columns and precedent can run Seco
on top of that time okay so so to make
things easy easy and you know sort of
touch Tidus bags like what we do right
so we contribute a lot to presto itself
to the core but also we tried to make it
more easy to use for for our customers
so we babe we do have our own offering
of presto on an LS marketplace and it's
fully integrated with Amazon services
like Amazon as free Google Catalog it
ties into also scaling available in LMS
which means that you can actually start
using first as a small class for five
ten nodes right pay as you go and then
if your needs grow you can sort of Auto
scale this to a larger number of
instances pay the paper for that spike
and then shrink back when you are not
using presto that's heavily what others
you know night hours we can hold dates
or something like this and then if you
reach sort of a certain scale you're
really big users some of our customers
you can sort of get an enterprise
license for us and so have custom
pricing as well and follow the links if
you want to learn details so we recently
also enter either age inside so you can
use first as an application on top of
age the inside which is their Hadoop
platform equivalent of EMR on the breast
and and on that platform you'll be
talking to blob storage data like
storage
hive meta so that ships will fetch the
insight and power bi and all that sort
of micro States ecosystem and it's also
great if you are if your company's
pursuing of hybrid cloud or multi clouds
and and strategy presto is a great
bridge right because you can serve your
use cases on-premises
but also at Everywhere's and now as you
write so we can sort of use the same
interface for your users across all
those environments and they don't need
to learn new syntax new language new
tools to interact with with sequel and
their data okay so it might be curious
like what makes presto fast and
appealing right so some of the internal
considerations that were part also the
initial design of presto and when
Facebook engineers started developing
this like those four guys who started
working on this project 2012 the
divisive talks of the best chapters from
the classic database architecture and
MPP sequel engine they took all those
best chapters back best practices and
developed first according to those sort
of state-of-the-art NPP engines right so
in many ways what the execution of
presto is very similar to you can what
you can find in database engines and you
know I would name things like say Metis
vertical green plan other red shift to
some extent right so some of those
considerations on the execution which
are very similar
which makes pressed uniquely position to
challenge those proprietary old-school
on data or solutions because is actually
following the same implementation sort
of design and details so its MPP engine
right
but unlike things like high for spark
that are optimized for fault tolerance
and long-running jobs environment that
can break and at anytime
Preston makes a trade-off of optimizing
everything for performance which means
the data intermediate data between virus
operators and stages is pipelined across
those workers in memory right and over
the network right so there's no like
check pointing making up sort of a
fallback mechanism right it's basically
pipelining intermediate results as soon
as possible and try to get to the answer
as quickly as possible right and that
basically means it can achieve great
latency at
the expense of fault tolerance right and
that's basically because presto was
developed to be this in our low latency
high performance high concurrency system
right so you don't expect quiz impressed
to run hours and the likelihood of
failure is pretty small if you're
running seconds worth of execution right
so it's easier to restart the query and
basically come up with the answer again
rather than to try to fall back to some
partial result because it's not worth to
redo that I mean we do have to redo the
old computation and an arrive at that
result faster than this is basically do
this step by step and retrace your don't
think so
that makes presto complimentary to some
of the technologies spark and and hive
because those guys are optimized for
long running jobs data pipelines
if you yell but they are not optimized
for low latency high concurrency were
close as the president's good at right
so those are the of the design
considerations and anyway so choose of
dive and performance right presto is
optimized for columnar vectorized
processing so internally it's data is
represented as a columns and vectors the
moment it gets out of the storage is
transformed into this internal
representation that's very efficient it
compiles the bytecode compiler query
into byte code to sort of save your CPU
cycles has of custom memory efficient
data structures internally to again make
fewer rounds of GC right and things
ideas and multi-threaded multi-core
execution stuff is trying to get as much
as CPU power out of your machines as
possible optimized for the color format
so if you already store data in your
color formats such as or C / K whereas
Hadoop or s3
presto will be having really optimal
path from those skolem storage on on
disk to internal in memory
representation is also columnar on and
then recently we introduced a cosmos
optimizer to presto which allows us to
execute very complex queries
much more efficient faster but also use
fewer resources and and basically
approach those speeds of the commercial
sequel engines to just quickly recap
what series and there's a whole
presentation I gave at the data were
examined earlier this year but we
basically leverage statistics initial
version in statistics from the hive
metal storage most of you already have
it and sort of saw your stats there and
we leveraged that to join you reordering
so if you have five joints we try to
predict which ones we should do first to
save you on memory and CPU and arrive at
better and performance at the end and
then we do things like decide
automatically which join type we should
use so you don't have to hint presto
whether it's using your partition
drawing your broadcast we can make this
decision automatically and we can also
pick left and right draw on a side of
join automatically for you again to save
your CPU and memory we have a whole
series of blog posts on the internal
design and implementation of cost-based
optimizer impressed on our blog and then
just to give you sort of a teaser of the
results right so if you compare presto
without CPU and then so far earlier ease
with Cpl with respect these back in and
of march those are some of the speed ups
you can achieve right so we take a very
complex workload and define in the tips
EGS benchmark which is essentially is a
real kind of workload with like 20-plus
tables and so on and so on and you see
the more complex queries we are
achieving higher speed outs because now
we can predict execution and/or what's
the optimal plan for to execute those
queries and and that means your quiz be
faster so your users will be happy all
right you'll be using fewer fewer
resources which allows you to run more
question concurrently and reduce maybe
your expenses on the actual hardware and
growth because you are just smarter how
you execute your workload and while you
can do lots of tuning manually
at some point a certain scale is just
impossible to predict all the user
queries right so you want severe to
solve those problems in majority of
times so that you don't have to do this
manually and actually our friends from
from Facebook when they pick up our work
on CBO and around us on their production
workloads and they were very impressed
because CBL was smart enough to
basically basically never regress versus
the highly tuned manually tune queries
that they had in production and also
uncovers some potential speed-up that
were not able to achieve by hand because
nobody thought about this particular
execution path on so it's actually
proving to be very efficient for even
for for smart engineers at Facebook and
if you're running in the cloud right so
what well doesn't mean right well you
can run your workload on fewer machines
right which means you have you paying
less right for Amazon infrastructure so
that's great you can run this faster you
can also execute more queries within
your constraints on your cluster so you
have 1020 nodes you don't want to expand
your cluster infinitely you can run more
queries without failures right because
you are not exceeding memory allocations
that are available to your cluster and
and that basically means you can either
run smaller cluster paralyze or
do more work more queries at the same
cluster right at the same cost right so
that's pretty amazing and so if when we
run the same workload on the Amazon
infrastructure we so you know over 60%
of queries almost two-thirds actually
are five times X or or faster right than
the baseline Presta from EMR that you
can get from Amazon right so it's pretty
amazing and we haven't seen any
regressions to so very good results full
detailed disclosure of this benchmark
estándares this URL if you're curious
and then you know you don't have to take
our word for this obviously we
contributed a lot
to this effort right but there are
independent studies right now on the web
from five Tran concurrency labs and and
a few other users and presto and they
basically compare and presto versus Park
Press 2 versus redshift press 2 versus
snowflake bigquery all this other
technologies and you can see how press
the first against those right and and
not to spoil the surprise but it
basically presto so if it's in the same
ballpark in terms of performance and at
very very good cost benefit as well so
you might want to check this out if
you're really unhappy with your of your
bills on other sequel engines ok cool so
just finish it off right like if you are
not using presto and you want help from
us you know one of yours of one company
that stuff helps to get you more out of
presto so we are sort of about a year
old but we actually were part of press
the community for over three years and
we are contributing a lot to this open
source project so we can you can see
contributions for our team on github we
have our own distribution of press tour
for on-premises and cloud environments
which is basically precut prepackaged
easier to use stable tested and you can
kind of think of us as you know like
cloud era was for hot for Hadoop right
or Hadoop like we kind of provide that
kind of level of service to the
community
and we support customers in production
24 by 7 right so if you want to roll
this in production and you know want to
own it all the time and you want you
want someone to call and fix the bag or
I'll charge the performance issues you
see right like we can help with those
banks and we have some subscription
add-ons for enterprise users too if
you're curious arm can discuss the
details and can check us out at the
table as well
and some of those major things that we
contributed to the open source to
everyone's benefit
is extensions to insist equal to make it
fully compliant various performance
improvements execution
security integrations as well like
Kerberos LDAP integrations spill today's
quite so if you're running out of memory
on your cluster you may want to sort of
have to spill to disk locally rather
than fail like we right so that's I
think we contributed and then Cosby's
optimizer was basically a major effort
that my team was pursuing for over a
year and we shipped that in in March and
contribute it back to the community as
well ok cool so that's all we have a
table outside if you want to grab a
t-shirt on Pengy and things like this
stickers you can fall news questo on
twitter blog and a newsletter and you
know obviously I'm hosting office hours
as well if you want to dive into details
really running first or you have some
challenges we like to show you
experiences always happy to help any
committee members and learn more about
price to users thank you so much so can
you use presto for like unstructured
data and can you use it like against no
sequel data stores that's one
and how does presto compared to
something like dream you yeah question
so we scroll back here so some of the I
guess no sequel engines that we support
today would be it's ready it's a chemo
Cassandra Kafka MongoDB those are
currently supported on we are hearing
about HBase all the better although less
than in the past but that's that's
another connector that might be
supported at one day yeah
do you need to predefine the schema hmm
so some of those engines expose sequel
like schemas of wisdom
Cassandra you can query and they will
give you a list of tables and list of
columns and things like that so some of
those do some of them like say [ __ ] you
have to think you have to apply some
mapping and I think that also applies to
Kafka you have to provide some mapping
in your configure so your connectors
like this glue that's between your data
source and suppressed so that connector
code typically comes with some
configuration and you can plug in
different things there to allow us to
understand better how to map this so
that the inherent data source schema -
so far more like database schema the
first I can understand yeah so it
depends on the connector exactly it's
all documented online if you'd like to
check it out this out but yeah oh yeah
the second question about the geranium
so Dremel is one of this examples of
Sikkim Hadoop that was developed by a
vendor called map or if I recall
correctly right is shipping with my
power distribution of presto it's a
party project right it is sequel I guess
when people ask me to compare this like
I think Dremel has this very neat angle
of like discovering your schema at
runtime like so you don't even have to
define it which is pretty amazing
feature on other than that I'm
personally not aware of like big
community users of dreamier that who so
show me numbers like like those which I
think the adoption shall be limited to
the map our user base and that's why I
don't know really publicly speaking
about this I have a question about how
you see customers use presto at least
when I first became acquainted with it
it seemed like more of an OLAP queries
in but it certainly makes it easy to run
batch style ETL because of the
connectors no it's kind of a debate we
always have internally and
curious what you see more people out
there using it for right so so I
mentioned earlier in my talk that presto
by design was optimized for those
shorter faster queries concurrency right
so that was true originally and it's
still true because Presta doesn't have
fault tolerance built-in right however
when you talk to some of those presto
users some of them use use Presta for
both video and and so low latency VI
kind of workloads even internally in
facebook they migrated off a bunch of
pipelines from hive which was obviously
fault tolerant but super slow at scale
right so they migrated to presto they
did some sort of engineering to break
those long queries into a series of
smaller quarries so that they can
actually like manually checkpoint right
the intermediate output to like disk
HDFS for example right and that way they
can enable some replay logic but because
of the benefits of press to speed they
can actually basically save 80 percent
of the cost of running that pipeline
which is a good trader of regardless so
reducible people playing with this idea
and doing this it's still not like a
common practice common practices still
use spark or or hive but I think it's
getting some popularity and if you do
it's so freezing all smart way I think
it can can help you there as well Thanks
one thing that pesto promises is you
know its ability to do federated queries
right it's so you know presto connects
with multiple databases so you know
let's say I have two or three databases
like my sequel Oracle and Terra data as
well right I get connected to all of
them but and I have a query that needs
to occur you know in
interview no get data from all these
three data sources you know can this be
done in a single query how often do you
see that in real real world
this kind of you know Multi multi
database based requirements yes yes sir
so definitely Prester can be used to
federate queries of virtualized data I
have virtualized data access so in
because in in your Presta system right
you can actually define multiple
catalogs and mount press like you have
personal cluster and then you say okay
this is my HDFS cluster this is how
you're accessed is this is my s very
compatible object store this is my
Cassandra and you can actually run
queries across them so which means you
can refer to tables from different data
sources that are mounted to the same
press to plaster and and I think I maybe
I skipped that detail right but first of
all actually pushdown processing to the
underlying data source for things like
perdicas and column selection so it will
only fetch the actual data that it means
for the particular query other than
bring entire data into preston right so
so it's very efficient on and and yes
you can run queries that are sort of
correlating data between different
systems and that's you know pretty
common use case - okay any last
questions one back here
hi
so my company's been using Amazon's
Athena which he mentioned before sort of
a manic version of presto honestly
sometimes banging our heads on the wall
with it because it seems to be claiming
to be server list but actually having
limits looking much more like a
traditional server so can you contrast'
ort of like your approach here is you do
have to sort of provision capacity ahead
of time how do you compare your approach
and overall performance with Athena I
see a lot of comparisons you have on
your blog with a presto on EMR but not
necessarily with Athena yep yeah great
great question so I would say yes so I
think I was built using Presta code
right it's exposing presto or query
interface and they basically picked a
different business model right they take
charge of per query right not per
cluster running Craster like normally on
ec2
but per query and they they look at how
much data you read and that's the basis
for for billing you're right so I've
well could we I mean honestly yeah this
obviously you can compete between these
two approaches right running the fixed
cluster or auto scale cluster that you
pay for compute or be charged per query
what we see a finger to be really
popular for is infrequent queries that
are unpredictable users once in a while
want to around a big query you don't
want to spin up a cluster manage the
whole infrastructure right yes it has
those limits and we heard that feedback
from our customers too you know that's
some quiz fail and so on so on you
cannot actually expand capacity to black
box it's a sequel interface that's it
right so it has those challenges in
terms of performance right so you have
to guys like what's behind the fina
right like some people say it's ten nose
20 nose whatever right so yes there will
be limits to how big queries you can run
in the fina no limits if you provision
your own presto cluster right because
you can scale it to 100 nodes whatever
right so no limits there if you're
running persistent workload loss of
course concurrently you probably want to
own the infrastructure because you are
not built per query right you just build
a fixed amount or more or less fixed
amount for for your
good time right so for real production
use cases we definitely recommend
getting your own plaster you can also
tune it for your workload which you
cannot tune Athena because again the
black box right so those are the
considerations right
[Music]